women have a need for like security yes  and when but women also are attracted to  men that can get other women  so  so it's kind of like a double-edged  sword we want to know that the guy we're  with can cheat  right we want to know that he can't i've  heard that i've  and this is the question would you  rather find out your guy  tried to screw another girl and got  rejected  [Laughter]  or screwed another girl  and what was the answer  you didn't  because if he gets rejected i'm with a  bum like why am i with you  because they because they always cheat  uglier right they never cheat with the  hotter girl  so if he's if he if the girl that's  uglier than me said no like why am i  with you